ich denke man immer so okay es war gar
nicht so schlecht gemacht hat
irgendwelche kranken menschen und
stammen für mich vor allem im boden oder
was geht ab hierzu am axen heute gibt es
einen münchen master wilders zusammen
mit wenig kraft und eigentlich ja wenig
crafter sorgt niemals krank kraft wenig
kraft mit wenige zeit ne runde und es
ist das thema ist lässt es aber
schwierig katze
ok nähe freunde das machen wir natürlich
mit aber ich hatte gehofft es gelb wolle
als und gibt's ja das wird cool gewesen
da wo sonst eine katze unterwegs hier
würde ich persönlich sagen okay du hast
ja schon erzählt dass du nicht so mega
gut hier drin bist da sind wir schon mal
zwei rot bisher extrem gut wenn der
tunnel überhaupt fertig
oft was für eine vision
das hat das meistens auch nicht bauen
kann nicht etwas bauen will dann ist es
meistens viel zu groß und dann brauche
ich viel zu lange so dass die zeit aus
feuchter nicht fertig sind
ach so du kannst aber theoretisch bauen
oder wien kann man nämlich gar nicht
wahr
also ich habe noch nie irgendein projekt
und schönes haus kann man mal machen
das ist bei mir auch so dann ist das
mittlerweile ganzen zeitweilig mit jedem
projekt durch dabei war wohnhäuser bauen
megaprojekt oder planung was habe ich
mir ein haus gebaut habe erst in in mark
habe ich ein haus gebaut aber alle
gewehr konntest du ja es ging also ich
hab halt in speed bild davon gemacht
selbst wird cloud gebaut hast du auch
selbst konzipiert es ja auch hier kaum
selector kaum zurück bei dir auf den
arsch von der kasse ich probiere
irgendwie ein bisschen rum zu tricksen
dass sich erhalten leben vergessen dass
ich keine echte katze bauen aber ich
habe mich bei dir aus dem beutel getötet
ich habe ja ich glaube ich werde richtig
zu tode geworden gewartet diese leine
lidschatten oder freunde gerücht dass
man den ausnahmen
wenn man aufnimmt finde ich zumindest
deshalb hoch gehen das wird sicher
explodiert
war der richtige gedanke aber ich habe
das so groß gebaut das problem ich zehn
minuten zeit hätte welche so gut dabei
wenn du zehn minuten zeit hat das sagst
du 60 minuten zeit
ich finde dass sie es
eine lustige idee online mag kann man
keinen text
ich habe ganz nachgebaut nicht
funktionieren denn partikels die musst
du die höchste mini an das muss debatin
gründer täglichen mit restlos haben
willst du ja ja da ist es einen roboter
in die luft geht auch ganz vergessen
das ist leicht übertrieben aber ich weiß
nicht ob das was taugt was sie hier
gemacht habe ich bin gespannt weil wir
die leute sollten besser bei mir sein
dass so ein kennst du diese katzen bäume
wo die drauf klettern der nutzer so was
habe ich gemacht
also ganz ehrlich nicht dass ich meinen
katzen aus es ist echt nicht besonders
schön weil es kein körpers kriegt von
mir noch so weit in das gesicht fertigt
die herzen so du hättest so ein gesicht
bauen können von der katze hält länger
vor das ja richtig schön das bin ich
meinen katzen und ich bin gespannt wie
das ankommt mini katzengroße er hat das
gemacht was ich machen wollte nun viel
kleiner
ja ich hab halt überdimensional und habe
voller geworden
da hätte ich auch nicht gedacht das war
nicht so schlecht geben
fest das ist auf jeden fall nicht so
sehr das ist doch mal eine katze oder so
achte soll wahrscheinlich echte eine
sein
hey wie kann das davor explodiert seien
und dass hier nicht das ist jetzt
eigentlich liegt aus
viele kleine katze nicht wirklich von
ihren amazing
aber ich war in mainz ein bisschen geht
schief alter das problem das ich hab'
ich hätte so eine katze bauen wollen
bisher saß ich habe viel zu groß gebaut
noch größer ist die hier ein assist 3 x
2 oder sowas oder nicht hier sogar
glaube ich müsste eigentlich ist eine
irgendwelche leute boten verfahren
irgendwas anderes aber ich glaube aus
der hand es geht nicht hoch könnte das
davor hochgehen lässt sich die unfair er
alles karten scheißhaufen wundervoll
geht das auch wieder nicht hochheben
verfehlung hast du geschrieben hast
nicht hochgegangen
was ist denn mit den leuten okay die ist
lustig diesfeld krieg vom weingut auf
jeden fall hätte die branche wolle
gedauert hätte wäre es egal ob es
rechtlich sehr richtig gut gehen
aber es gibt ja es gibt leute die nach
diesen pixel abbauen
ich habe extra ist es das bein gemacht
wie katzen echtes mit niemals in dem
veräußerer extrem gut gebauten sein aber
trotzdem weiß nicht fertig ist kann ich
leider nur ein freundschaftliches okay
geben
mein problem ich denke mir immer so ok
es lange schlecht witze macht lassen
dann kommt halt irgendwelche kranken
menschen
start für mich vor allem boden und ich
bin wieder das wort was vorletzter der
scheißhaufen war dann sogar vor mir weil
das ja nicht mal explodiert
oman leute habe ich das verdient
schreibt in die kommentare
das hat euch gefallen
wenn ihr den ihr sehen wollt geht auf
seinem kanal ein verdammt noch mal
tschüss